hey what's up my name is Samuel leads
and in this video I wanted to do a Q&A
this every single week where I give you
the opportunity to ask me questions and
I answer them every week on a Sunday so
if you've got a burning niggly property
question buzz below and then it might be
that I answer it next week so let's have
a look at what we got this week we've
got quite a few really good freshers
actually like Ross Jackson asked hi
Samuel any tips and tricks for meeting
HMO standards fire doors alarms posted
carpet etc now there is a very special
website and on this website that you go
to it will tell you your specific area
of all the different rules and
regulations that there are to do with
HMOs and the very special website is
write this down w WG o GL Google you
know Google is a fabulous place you can
get so much information for free on
Google let's say that you're based in
Birmingham you're thinking right
Birmingham yeah oh yeah per my gun HMO
license right at the very top Birmingham
gov dot uk' boom comes up what is a
hmm-hmm standards what which properties
need to HMO we click on this we will be
able to download a very special pack and
you can do this you can go to any counts
or ask these questions guidance document
that's the one download and there we
have it folks Birmingham City Council
and this is all about HMOs it's like the
best tech ebook ever and you can get
this from any council website what is a
HMO what is actual households which each
HMOs need a license and this goes
through toilet facilities absolutely
everything room sizes kitchen facilities
come IRA's aunties all the reasons and
tips and tricks and what requires I hate
mo license of what doesn't you can even
ring up the council and you can ask them
someone to come down to your house that
you're planning on turning into HMO and
get them to give you a free assessment
they might charge you sometimes like 70
pounds often they'll do it for free and
they'll just give you the absolute load
under whether this property will get
licensed how to get a license it's just
absolutely brilliant the resources are
everywhere so hope that answers your
question more than now there's some
really good ones we have one Johnny
Ramos says hey Samuel what exactly is a
packaged deal hmm what is a package deal
I guess you speak two different probably
sources they'll give you different
answers in my notes a package deal is a
property that you have ready to sell
you've packaged it to then sell it on
for a fee a finder's fee what is a
package deal when are used to package
deals I don't really do it anymore
because I don't want to compete with my
success students so I'll let them
package and sell all the deals but a
package deal is when you found a project
you've put in an offer the offer has
been accepted
usually a negotiated a below market
value price you've calculated what the
rents will be on the property you've
checked the area route you've put
together a letting agent or a power tube
so that it's all lined up ready to go
basically it's when you put together as
if you were going to buy the property
yourself you do all those diligence all
the research on the property but then
you charge somebody for the privilege of
buying the property instead of you you
charge for your time so that's what a
package deal is it's a fantastic way to
make money and it's a really good way to
get experience in property and to begin
building relationships with agents
building a power team with no money of
your own and to make a very good living
doing it so that's your question let's
see what else we got next question is
from nerve in do the fam'ly who says
when obtaining a bridging loan however
excuse it to get and how should I do it
I'm really interested in this great
property but wanna buy it for a bridging
loan and then refinance is that okay in
a video I couldn't possibly say with us
okay without knowing what the property
is but what I will say is this when you
are getting a bridging loan is it risky
it's only risky if the properties are
bad property if the property is a good
property then it's not risky what a
bridging loan is is it's a short-term
loan to buy a property you'll normally
pay very high interest but you'll only
borrow the money for a short period of
time typically between four and twelve
months you'll borrow the money because
you you don't want to use your own or
you haven't written your own you'll then
add value to the property and then
you'll take out a normal Violette
mortgage
and with the bind to let mortgage with
the money that they give you you'll then
pay off the bridging loan you'll pay off
any money that you borrowed so that's
how the strategy works and there's three
figures that you need to know to work
out if a property is a good property
deal or not for this strategy the first
thing is are you buying it below market
value
what's the purchase price the second
thing is what is the refurb costs going
to be and the third figure you need to
know is what's the N value gonna be
what's the done-up value so once you've
got these three figures you can work out
it's a good deal or not
and typically I like to see that the
purchase price plus the refurb cost
adding up together are a lot less than
the done up value that's the case get a
bridging loan you'll be a very happy
person whether you'll be able to get a
bridging loan or not depends more on the
property than on you
bridging lenders don't really care about
yet they care about the deal they care
about whether the property is a good
deal or not so if you've got not
particularly great credit if you've got
not / - good experience if you're really
old with young it shouldn't matter too
much as long as the deal is good
so get educated and get good at finding
good deals and then it should all come
together so I hope that helps and good
luck in your property purchase I wish or
less with that all right let's see if we
can just find one more question we've
got a guy called a true boss 135 he says
Samuel I was browsing through properties
today and I kept coming across the
properties to be sold
unseen no viewing no survey access
obviously sounds really dodgy but allows
you to get a good buyer's position what
do you think about properties like these
have you ever bought any of a hit or
miss thanks I've bought many properties
without looking at them this doesn't
sound right that this does not sound
right if they're saying that there's no
access to the property at all but
expecting you to buy it that's really
weird like I can't imagine you said you
can't you keep coming across this I
don't know what town or country you're
in but that is weird
although I buy houses without looking at
them if I'm not looking at the property
people said that's a risky Samuel why
would you buy a house without looking at
it the reason is because someone's
looking at it just not me and the person
that's looking at it is probably much
more confident and competent than I am
if I'm not buying it but I'm getting a
survey on it it doesn't matter because
as long as I get a good survey on it
someone who's got all the tools and the
equipment they're gonna have a bear up
then I would just with my naked eye
because they've got all the tools
they've got all the qualifications never
buy a property without anyone looking at
it but feel free to buy a property
without you looking at it yourself
it's all about the formulas it's all
about the figures the reason I don't
care about looking at it myself is
because I don't care what I think of the
property I don't care how I feel about
the property all I care about is what
the figures are what am I putting in
what am I getting out and I don't need
to visit the house to know that but a
true boss definitely don't buy unless
someone is able to get into the property
because even if you think you've got a
real good deal if the house is falling
apart the house that you've been a
survey on it
super respect anyway guys thanks so much
for listening it's always cool hanging
out and Sunday I'd love to read more
questions I love reading all your
questions and I'll answer as many as I
can so comment below with your niggly
property questions and I look forward to
seeing you next time
thank you so much
[Music]
you